*Hits mic* Boink
*Hits other mic* Boink
Mark and Ethan (together)
YES
We Should Be Live
We Should Be Rolling
We should be live
Mark: Welcome every body.
Mark: Welcome to the stream!
All: Welcome all of you.
All:  Every one is welcome here!
All: At The Str-e-e-e-e-a-a-a-a-a-h-h-h-h
Ethan: Good Great Start, that was a Great start
and when your here
at the stream
we will raise money
for Crisis Text Line So
Look down in the description below for
press the donate button
down there
and you
can donate
to Crisis Text Line
you can also
buy a t-shirt
at Markipliers.fanfiber.com
links also in the description
if you donate
(laughs)
one other thing that we didn't mention already
is that if you go to Crisis Text Line
website you can actually look
up ways to also help out
without just donating money you can volunteer
oh yes
it is an emotional job but
they always need people to help out
so it is a great cause
hopefully everything is running smoothly
could you uhhh
pop on headphones and just double check that
everything is A-OK
(Off Screen: " I don't know what that Means")
You don't know what that means?
(Again "I don't know what that means")
Go on either your phony
I think my computer shut off
so you have to press the thingy
nope it's on the side
we've already raised 177.65$
$177.65 cents (After correction intially)
echo echo
Oh man
I think it's an echo because we're all saying it
yeah wait
there might also be an echo because of all
the mics
yeah that might be it hang on
No... It wouldn't be that (It probably is tbh)
It might be that
It might be that.. I think it is that (Captioner called it :P)
oh no
Because we never did a test recording (that's a good idea -captioner)
We did
Nah
It sounded great
Well we're about to find out
Hang on
Sorry
What's your password (Off screen at computer)
No don't say it outloud!
You should know what it is, did you not put a hint on there?
I don't know
Incorrect
Hold
Ok I got it
I need to get my glasses (grunt)
We're good we're in
Welcome to the live stream
(silence)
-Oh there is an echo
Where is it from?
I can't tell
I think it's cause
probably the two inputs
They are probably slightly delayed from each other
Just pull the other one, pull
Pull the top one just pull it
Just pull it out
Pull it Pull it
And then take this one away
This one? -Yeah
Ok
Wait
Uh oh - I just heard something
I think it was the microphone -Oh Ok
Ok
All captions done by first time captioner Harris feel free to shout me out in the comments (Edited (And reviewed) by Wulf715) (Your welcome.)
Now
Is that betttteeeeerrrrrrr?
Orrrrrr
Woooorrrrrssssseeeee
Onnee orrr the otthhheeerrr
Make your choice (Ominous Voice)
This is how we're going to do the whole stream? (Laughing)
Just talking in unison?
Yes
Ok that fixed it
Alright cool so we're just going to distribute these generally
What we'll do is we'll do the cross pattern
One shooting that way from over there
and one shooting that way from over there
This one's aimed at him this one's aimed at us
that should be
can you move it more towards me that one's right at-
there you go know it's pointing
alright and this one just a little farther
and hopefully
That will be better
if it's not better it is uh
stupid
can you hear me?
It's good -It's good?
it sound good?
do we all sound relatively level
relatively- ok good
right we tried to do uh
three mic setup because
there is three of us
But for some reason if
anyone knows how to use
the scarlett 18i8 and get 3 microphones in to output
to x-split let me know
cause I was troubleshooting last night and
I coudn't figure it out
and it doesn't seem to work so I might just go
go with a different interface at that point
but that isn't important all that's all technically information
bull-crap
so we should talk about our goal for today
what? what? -what? (from all around the room)
(Inaudible talking in voices)
money raised
so we are going to be here for 12 solid hours plus a few minutes
just cause we are a little bit late
but when have I ever done a charity livestream I started on time?
Never -Never (It's true)
ever ever ever
That's gonna try to change
Please
Hey who's the guy -Don't even
I told you to have everything setup
last night
Is it your job to tell me what to setup or
It is my job to tell you
Let's be honest no one watched these captions so that's a half an hour wasted but it's for charity so good cause right?
(Bai - Editors)
so yeah we're uh